Athletic World, an athletic training camp in your own home.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike.
I'm Joe. And I'm Sean.
Sean, do you have something in your mouth?
No. Okay.
You just sounded like you were having a moment to get through that.
I don't know what you're talking about. This episode is sponsored by Jolly Ranchers.
No, do not say that.
No, of course not.
This episode is also live, but in a weird sense that it's live for us, not live for you guys.
It's the first episode we've done that way.
So we're not taking any breaks in case we mess up.
We're not taking any breaks or anything like that.
And if you hear ambulances in the background and stuff, just know that we live in New York City.
And that's what you usually hear.
We just have a less soundproof room today.
It's okay, though.
We're not homeless or anything.
Yeah. So maybe we should talk about the games now.
What game are we doing, Mike?
We're doing Athletic World, the one that is like an athletic camp in your own home.
But it's like, why did they just say it's like an athletic world in your own home?
That's exactly what I thought when you read the box.
I was like, well, that's kind of a downgrade.
Yeah. You just said Athletic World and now it's just a camp.
This game also is made by human entertainment.
Can we talk about that?
I feel like this is like an alien or a robot is trying to blend in with us.
Yeah, human entertainment.
Human entertainment.
Yeah. And they're known for, this is a weird connection, but remember when I talked about Fire Pro Wrestling?
Yes. That thing that you guys didn't know about, but I'm like, it's still a series that's being made today.
They worked on that.
Wow. Yeah. So I don't know if there's, no, they went defunct in January of 2000.
They were replaced by robot entertainment.
Wait, it doesn't matter.
That's not true.
Sorry, you got me.
So human entertainment developed this game and it was published by Bandai.
How do we feel about Bandai guys?
Bandai is a kind of a dump.
Yeah. They're, you know, they're the, the fighting wrestling games that we hated.
The muscle guys. Muscle tag team wrestling, but they were also the other one too, weren't they?
They were tag team wrestling.
They did both? Yeah.
I think they did both. Oh no.
Tag team wrestling was Data East.
Yeah. Geez. Yeah.
Well, when the garbage looks so similar, you know, like that's kind of how I always used
to. Was this my bag from a happy meal from last week or the week before?
Right. Exactly. And the chubby cherub, another one from them.
Oh yeah. So I wasn't really like feeling the Bandai drought because we never really knew what a
good Bandai game could be.
Right, Joe? That sounds about right.
Okay, good. So athletic world was one of, it's like the first of 10 games that Bandai released in
the family trainer series, which is like part of the family fun fitness thing that involves
the Nintendo power pad.
Wow. Yep.
So obviously we have to talk a little bit about the power pad, but here's where I also
have to mention that the womp womp moment, which is that we bought two power pads because
none of us grew up with a power pad.
Yeah. Did you ever see one before?
I never saw a power pad.
I hadn't either. No. And so like, yeah, it was actually kind of like magical when I opened it up from, I had
to buy it from eBay. And so I bought it from eBay, came in the mail and I opened it up and I was like, this is
really cool.
There's something like this existed.
Like this was cooler than Rob in my opinion.
Yeah. Oh yeah. Like this is like a virtual reality for, you know, people without headsets.
Yeah. All of a sudden I was thinking like, you know, if you're a kid and you're using those buttons
on the power pad to like walk, but Mario's walking in Super Mario Brothers, like that's
pretty cool. And you could do that for the record.
I don't want to, I don't want to make it seem like you couldn't do that.
Power pad did have like mapping for, you could play Mario with the power pad.
Yeah. For which game you were playing.
And it would like think that it had, but it really wasn't doing anything.
Probably like they weren't like, Oh, Ghostbusters just came out on NES.
So let's program our coding for the power glove.
Probably just makes it a more like intuitive button mapping or something.
Well, so, you know, and nothing was intuitive about either one of these things.
Cause the sad part is that finding a working power pad is incredibly tough.
Uh, after attempt number two.
Both DOA. Yeah. Well, here's the interesting thing.
So I was willing to be like, maybe it's the NES or even after we plugged it into, um,
Mezin, the NES emulator.
I was like, Oh, maybe it's the, um, maybe it's the emulator.
Who knows? But I was able to go in and actually like change input settings for some of them.
Oh. So some of the power pads on both power pads were registering.
Were like recognized by the people.
They were, they were registering certain inputs, but not all of them.
And that made playing these games with the power pad impossible.
Uh, we will have another chance at redemption here because athletic world will just become stadium events.
So when we review that game, we'll just pretty much be like talking shortly about this.
How we played it.
Not far off. So, um, so we'll have a chance to do this with the power pad again.
If anybody has a working power pad.
Can you please give that to us?
Well, I think like, well, here's the thing.
I'm, I'm, that's, that, that's the ideal situation.
But I'll level with the listeners out there.
I mean, I'm willing to pay for the shipping back and forth too, if, if necessary to like.
Oh, if they want it back. If you want it back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. They'll probably want it back.
Right. And this way we get like a guaranteed working one instead of I keep buying from these eBay
people who are just like, well, I found this at a garage sale, so it must work.
We will not steal it.
We, we. Thank you.
That's something we should always put at the end of every episode.
We won't steal your stuff.
As a listener, when you send me your email and you can email us at contact that nostalgia
case. Like when you do that, I promise that I won't give it to big pharma.
I'm never going to give that email off to big pharma or Monsanto or anything like that.
So. So let's talk about athletic world guys.
Joe, you want to give me first impressions without the power pad?
Well, so leveling with you.
I couldn't get it to work either way.
So I watched a couple of videos about this.
And my first impression is like, well, that would be very impressive in, in 1987 to have
this pad and like it's registering what you're, what you're doing when you're running.
I mean, that pretty unprecedented in your home.
Right. At that point.
Yep. Um, so it looked like it would be pretty impressive.
Then I was just watching the videos and it's very basic, very simple.
Um, I guess I'm the most curious as to how well this power pad actually registers.
So that's kind of like my like looming question to this whole time playing it.
It was like, would this work?
Well, would this be fun?
Joe, uh, knowing your experience just with toys in the nineties, uh, and stuff like that.
I think you did how well they all work.
Yeah. And how well they all work.
Like, were you expecting this?
I think that this must be very responsive and very helpful.
Yes. Uh, Sean, first impressions.
Um, yeah, I would, uh, my, most of my time that I spent in the early, uh,
uh, moments of this game was, was just trying to configure, uh, the emulator.
And, um, I would say that it was, it was interesting to try and figure out like, this is not how the
game is supposed to be played. So it was interesting to try and figure out the best way to approximate that.
Um, because I just had to use like keyboard buttons to pretend that I was a standing little,
little finger boy.
Um, and then you were using your hand as a puppet.
Yeah. I was, I was a puppet master.
Um, so I would, um, I would imagine that like kids, I mean, maybe they tried to play the game.
They tried to like hack the game by like getting on the, on the ground and like sort of like tapping
on the, uh, power pad with like with their fists or something.
Maybe this is like sort of how like kids may have tried to play the game before, but yeah,
I mean, it was fine.
I'm sure that it would be a lot more fun if I was standing on it.
Um, but yeah, no, it was, it was weird.
All right. So here's where my first impressions come in and I'm gonna tell you right now, this is controversial
probably, but I didn't care that I didn't have the power pad.
I thought it was, I thought it was like probably more fun doing it this way, but maybe this
is because I'm a guy who hates like the dance dance revolution games and stuff like that.
So I just wasn't looking forward to ever using my feet controls on a map.
And remember, you know, we talked about in the track and field episode, like I'm a runner.
I should be into that kind of thing.
Right. It's like, I should be pretty good at these games.
I don't care to find out how fast I can run on a power pad by mashing my feet up and down
to me, if they would have just made that the A and B buttons on the NES controller, it would
have felt like the same thing to me.
I understand that this is part of a family fitness thing that Bandai was just trying to
do with, with the power pad accessory.
So I don't think like, I understand why they didn't map it to a controller, but having just
played track and field, you know, that was like what, two or three episodes ago.
Now having just played track and field, I feel like this game is, is worse on every possible
scale compared to track and field.
And they're two different games.
Yes. Because one does require the mat, but I I'm a huge fan of track and field because of the
way that it, you know, uses the controller.
And I'm a huge fan, not fan, not fan, anti fan of athletic world, because I feel like
it just forced a gimmick onto you that kind of like how Rob wasn't necessary to play those
games. You know, it was just like, Rob's an added step.
Like you could just play them without him.
See, why do you have to be such a downer?
Like, you know, we're trying to have fun with this, with this peripheral that we can't
use. And like, you're saying that you didn't even try it.
And it's garbage.
Okay. Here's the thing though, Sean.
It's not that I think that the idea is garbage.
I think that's a fun idea for 1986.
I know it's garbage today.
Like I like if that was the gaming revolution, we would have had, we all would be very fit
people who play Call of Duty on like these 360 degree treadmill.
See, that's still something I want though.
It's still something I want.
I mean, not Call of Duty, but I'm sorry.
I guess like, here's my thing.
I think it sounds cool.
But do you actually want that?
Like, would it, would it be awesome to like be on a treadmill and play Fallout?
Here's not. It doesn't sound un-awesome.
My input on that.
I think it would be cool if you could actually have like a working crazy, like 360 treadmill
that you're running around the Skyrim world or whatever.
But also, I do sometimes like to be like, I want to relax and play a video game.
So like, I don't want that to be what video games are is like, it's almost like, you know,
it's like you get home from a long day of work and you're like, I just can't wait to go sit
down and play athletic.
Oh, wait a minute.
Better hit the gym.
Get the towels, buddy.
Well, then you just play something else.
Right. Also, this isn't like hitting the gym though.
Like this is like that whole Wii Fit myth, you know, where like people bought Wii Fits
and the scales they were doing the hula hoop game and be like, oh,
I'm losing weight. It's like, you're not like, get a diet.
Wow. Not, no, no, not that anybody needed it.
If your goal was to lose weight, you should have just went on a diet.
I feel like we are, we're being very mean right now.
Then I'll say something kind of nice.
I can't promise it's too nice.
But when I was watching, you know what, I'm just talking like, don't people like Wii?
Oh, the Wii Fit?
Yeah. The Wii Fit was fun.
Yeah. I mean, Wii Fit trainers in Smash Brothers.
Yeah. Obligatory Smash Brothers mention.
I'm just, yeah, you're right.
I understand. I'm just messing around.
We have to talk, we're not just talking about the game here, right?
Yeah. Because this is the family, this is the whole thing.
We're talking about the concept of a physical.
We're talking about life. Yeah.
I'm sorry to interrupt you, Joe.
No, it's fine. What were you going to say?
No, my thing that, it's hard to say anything positive or negative about something you only
watched a video for.
But while I was watching someone actually using the power pad, I was like, oh, that's kind
of, it looks like it could be kind of cool if it all worked well.
Like the way you side, it wasn't the fact that you're running, that you're mashing the
two buttons to run. It was like, oh, they programmed in a way to duck where you have to like put your feet and
your hands on the mat.
So you max, you duck. And I was like, that's kind of clever.
And even the jumping is clever.
And it, and it's just interesting that they do it that way because I think if you turn
it back to buttons, right?
So for those of you that don't know, jumping is just not having any inputs on the ground
because if you're not on the power pad, you must be in the air, right?
There's no other alternative.
And naturally gravity will bring you back down to the, to the, to the power pad earth.
But if you're using the keys to do that, right?
If you're doing like, you know, AB, AB, AB, and then you press off of both of them.
You still have to go back to hitting AB, AB immediately.
You have to sort of like rewire, you have to rewire your brain a bit.
So when you take your, your fingers off the keyboard, does your guy jump and just float
there until you put your fingers back down?
Or does he not jump? For the most part.
He does have like a limit to his, to his jumping lane.
Yeah. You can't jump forever.
But I don't think that there are a lot of, there are a lot of jumps that I feel like
you sh- you can't clear.
Thank you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Select them.
For sure. But the thing is, is so like hurdles, right?
Yeah. Let's just talk about that.
You are, you're running on the trackpad.
You left foot, right foot, left foot, right foot.
Yeah. You jump in the air to jump over the hurdles.
When you land, you land.
It, it doesn't, it doesn't seem like the best way to, like, I don't know another way to do
it with the power band, but I just think that the NES track and field hurdles was more fun
than this. Well, that's again.
And more intuitive and responsive.
But again, that's because like, we're not physically doing it.
I think that if we had the peripheral, we wouldn't find it a blast, but it would probably like,
it would differentiate itself more from track and field.
Sure. But I guess what I'm saying too, is that like, all right, so let's, you know, if you have
the power pad, right.
I'm still saying that the responsiveness of the, of even just the game itself, as I was
playing it, like the way that the jump in this game works and the, and the hurdles and stuff
with that, and how you, you know, how you have to time it, it's not, it doesn't feel as responsive
and intuitive as track and field.
I found it to, I mean, I found it to be more precise than you're making it out to be, but
I guess, I don't know.
It was just a different experience, I guess.
I just felt like the, even the, like, first off, the graphics in this game are pretty weird.
They look different than most NES games.
They almost look like drawings.
I thought it was neat, but the, the jumps and stuff like that, like, like they're pretty,
they're pretty weird arcs and stuff like that.
They're definitely not, they're not responsive to how you're actually jumping in the real world.
Yeah. They, you know, they hang up as long as you're hung up, but there is like more of a, it's
like a lunge to it.
I don't know. It just bothered me that it wasn't.
Well, I think it's more because, um, it's a binary.
Um, it's a binary of either you are on the ground or you are like three feet up in the
air. So it looks weird, but I think that in order for the game to work in, like when you're
playing it physically, it sort of has to do that.
I don't know.
I think that whatever I'm going to say about this game, it's just going to be that it's
a bunch of half baked ideas.
Like, you know, like, like, it's like, oh yeah, cool.
And then it just never finishes out.
You know, even the, um, like the hop a log, right?
Yeah. It's like, you have to jump between the logs and the way to go about like changing between
logs is just from running in the middle of your pad, running in the bottom of your pad,
running in the top of your pad.
And it's like, just, you know, just that that's the idea of changing and stuff like that.
It doesn't, it doesn't seem like you're supposed to hop, like hop on one leg.
But again, no, I agree.
It's their half baked ideas, but, um, I don't know how either of the track games that we played
so far have justified their existence with only like, you can finish a game in 20 minutes.
Right. And like, yeah.
Think about like a half baked idea is suddenly like to these, to these developers, I guess
seems like it's like suddenly more justifiable with like a peripheral.
Like even now, you have like a half, you have a game that would never be fun on a controller,
but you're like, oh, but we'll make it a motion control.
Think about all those Kinect games.
Right. They had the Kinect Star Wars game, the Kinect Dragon Ball Z game.
It's like, those would have never been games if you were just playing them with a controller,
but because all of a sudden you're using your hands, it's like, sell anything.
Yeah. It's sad.
So which one do you guys feel then has more replay value?
Are you saying that?
No, it's definitely track and field.
I think track and field has more replay value if only because.
It's still technically possible to play.
Yes. It's still technically possible to play.
And because you're, you know, you're racing your times and you're racing the computer.
Whereas here you're just kind of like, you know, maybe this is something Sean wants to talk about.
But when you finish through the entire course, the only thing you're really rewarded with is like a certificate.
Yeah. You get, like when you start a game, you sort of enter your, like you fill out a worksheet sort of like you type in.
Well, you're going to camp. Yeah.
You're going to camp.
You type in your name. I guess I never, I just, I never noticed the camp conceit while I was playing.
Yeah. Neither did I. The back of the box.
But like, yeah, it does make sense now that you were hopping on logs and going through an animal trail and in the dark tunnel.
Yeah. I mean, I don't know about any camps that have dark tunnels that are, that look like old tombs.
But yeah, when you start the game, you fill out your name, your age, your gender, your, like the date, this whole thing.
And then you just play the game and then it'll apparently.
You didn't have to sign an oath? I didn't have to sign an oath.
But apparently it changes the scoring depending on all that information that you gave, like age and weight.
Well, probably, yeah, your age and you did give your height and weight.
I actually don't remember if I had to put height and weight.
But regardless, it changes based on those, those variables.
It makes sense. Yeah. And then you do the weird stuff with the, with the tomb.
And then you go down a raft and you try to like, it's a very dangerous camp.
It's a very dangerous camp.
Yeah. It's like Camp Krusty in that SpongeBob, SpongeBob Simpsons episode.
Um, when you, um, it's like season four and they go to Camp Krusty and it turns out to be like not associated with Krusty the Clown at all.
Yeah. Uh, there's like, there's bottomless pits and everything.
So you, uh, you do all that and then at the end you get a, uh, certificate that again lists your name and all that other information.
And it'll tell you like in what, I guess, percentile you finished in and whether it was expert or beginner.
And I don't know, like you take a picture of that and show it to your friends.
You got one of those certificates too?
I mean, I, what was it?
It showed up on my screen.
Right. I was, I was the sixth, sixth level or like.
What percentile is that?
I, I guess like 40th.
Okay. No, I mean that, no, no, not top 40, like top 60.
Top 60. Yeah.
Because you know, a lot of it was just me like not knowing how to button mash correctly.
Um. Do you feel like you earned it?
Do you feel like you earned that certificate?
Absolutely not. Because I wasn't physically doing anything except with my fingers.
If you had like an NES printer, remember there was like the Game Boy camera and the Game Boy printer?
Yeah. Would you have wanted to print out this certificate?
Am I 27 years old?
No, you're a kid. Okay.
You print out this certificate?
I'd probably print it out and show my friends.
Even though you're only in like the 60th percentile.
Oh, no, not that one.
Sean, I made a few calls to Bandai.
And I know the listeners can't see this, but I have here a printed out certificate of your certificate from your game yesterday.
Okay. We'll have to take a picture of me.
Yes. We'll post this on the Twitter account.
You'll see. We're just going to like make my face censored.
Sean, you can go and accept your degree.
Oh, thank you. Thank you. I know you said you're not proud of it and it kind of broke my heart a little bit, but.
You should be proud of it. You don't feel like you earned it.
Yeah. You don't feel like you earned it?
Technically, he didn't.
He cheated. I mean, he played with the keys.
I'd like to thank my mom.
Okay. Who was always there for me.
Great. I'd like to thank you guys for giving me the opportunity to play this game.
Mm-hmm. And that's about it.
And that's just a temporary one, too.
You'll get a professional glossy print.
Yeah, thank you. Thank you.
Do you guys remember when your camp counselors made you run through a dark tunnel that was just mostly uphill?
And do you remember when your camp counselor made you run with the wild boars and then every time you got hit by one, you'd fall and die?
Yeah. I remember dying three times.
Oh, yeah. It's so bizarre, but at the same time, I don't know.
I briefly mentioned the graphics, but it's just something I liked about the game.
Probably the only thing I really liked about it.
Oh, you liked it?
Because you didn't really give a qualitative response to the graphics.
Yeah, I think the graphics. You just said they were weird.
The graphics are a thumbs up to me.
I think they're just weird in the sense that there's a way that NES games look, and then there's athletic ones.
Yeah, there's a certain look of NES games that I don't know why in my head when I see something that stylized the way this game was,
it makes me feel like it's a preschool game.
It's like a little education.
You know what I mean? It's something about it.
This did make me feel like it was an education game.
Maybe there's just like a LeapFrog look.
Right. What was that?
Is it called LeapFrog? Yeah, the little handheld thing.
Yeah, the VTech stuff, too, was like that.
And then one other thing I wanted to say was, other than the idea of the concept and stuff like that, I know that you guys didn't really get a chance to do it the correct way.
Mm-hmm. But did doing any of this game make you feel like, now I've got to do it the correct way, like I really want to go back and try it the correct way, or have you had your fill?
I'm curious.
I mean, like, yeah, I'm not...
I'm sorry.
No, it's live. It's okay.
Do it. Okay.
What's up, guys? Guys, I'm not going to say that, like, I want any physical motion device.
Like, I didn't want to connect.
I didn't want a move.
I didn't want an iToy.
But I at least wanted to try them.
Like, I think it's still cool to be able to manipulate a game, like, physically.
I do think that's the difference between you and me here.
Yeah. Is that I had all that stupid stuff.
I had the iToy.
I'll stand by iToy.
I love the iToy. I liked iToy.
The Samba de Amigo version of iToy was very fun.
I never was able to play the iToy.
Anyway, yeah, the iToy, I had the Wiimotes, obviously.
I had, I'm trying to think of, like, all the other...
I mean, I just even had, like, plug-and-play VR stuff that never really worked, you know?
Yeah. And my brother brought a Kinect just to try to hook it up to his computers,
just to make control the computer with his hands, like he would be the mouse, you know?
Just, these are the crazy things that people do when they're, like, big technology.
How awful that would be.
Right, they think technology is, like, further than it is, you know?
Yeah, he wants to go into minority report.
Right. So this is what happens, and I think now I'm just, I'm old enough and jaded enough by the experience
to know that, like, this isn't gonna be fun when we get into that.
I'm gonna find it fun.
I'm... At least for 20 minutes.
I want, I really want to play it.
Not because I want to be, I want to find out, is this an amazing game?
Yeah, no. I want to find out, like, how did this work back then?
Like, how well did this work?
And, yeah, and I feel like it probably would be a good time, like, for a minute.
Especially. It might be the most fat cat thing Sean has ever said on the podcast, though, where he's like,
Yeah, I want to buy a copy of Athletic World and the Power Pad so I can play this game for 20 minutes.
Hey, it's not entirely...
For the cost of some people's weeks of dinners.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna have to...
Okay, look, we have to, we have to do it.
Look at all the games that we bought and paid for already.
Might as well keep going.
That's the other thing for me, though, is I feel a little guilty recording this episode.
Not having played the game, like, it's the first time that that's happened.
And I feel like it's tough to give a fair opinion.
Well, I made an attempt at least.
No, no, it's good. There was an attempt.
I just watched the video.
And now there will be an attempt at voting in the Essential Games list.
Guys, I think somehow we've already voted.
If you think about it, like when we were just, the way we were talking about the games.
But I'm willing to be surprised.
So, Joe, your vote on Athletic World.
I'm going to say no.
But I'm going to put, even though I can't even imagine a scenario where I play this game for real
and decide that it is essential, I gotta put an asterisk there.
Like, I haven't actually played this game.
So, no with an asterisk.
Once I play it, I'll come back and I'll confirm that no.
Almost 100% positive.
But... And I'll let you do that.
That sounds great. Okay, Sean?
Sean? I'm also going to say no.
I mean...
Asterisk? No.
I mean, yeah, but it's not going to change anything.
Like, anything with an asterisk still counts as a no.
Got it. So, it's like, I'm never going to think that this was the best game of all time.
Um, I still want to try it out, though.
Like, just because I didn't get that opportunity.
To me, this game is practically obsolete.
Uh, like...
Everything we've been doing for the past, like, however long we've been doing this is obsolete,
Mike. No, I...
Yeah, yeah. I guess I just meant more so because the very object it depends on is, like, in...
You know, it's like, when are we ever...
Like, we're running out of working power pads.
You know? Like, we need a third-party company to step in and make amazing power pads with today's standards.
Cool. And until...
Until they do that, I'm voting no.
But even once they do it, I'm...
I'm 99% positive that I would vote no again.
These games just...
I'm not sold on them.
Uh, you know, I was not...
I was not a proponent of, um...
Donkey Kong Jr. Math.
I wasn't a big fan of that.
Oh, yeah. I thought that was terrible.
And I'm not a big fan of the Rob games, obviously.
I wasn't even a fan of Donkey Konga.
Well, I love Donkey Konga.
Well, that's your problem. So that's where you're wrong.
Um, rhythm games can be good.
I want to state... I want to just state that.
Rhythm games can be good.
Games that use gimmicks can be good.
There are many good Wii games that are just not playable today if you don't have the Wii
mode. Like, you can't just be, like, Switch port when, because they'd have to redesign the game.
I think one that's really guilty of that is Skyward Sword, but I don't think that's a great
one, necessarily. It's not a great game.
Is it a hot take? It's...
Uh, I think it's kind of a hot take.
I think people have started to realize, like, when that game came out...
The hive mind has started to sway.
Yeah. When that game came out, people were giving it tens, and everybody got very excited.
And I think tens are crazy for a game like that, because you constantly are getting tutorials
for the entire game.
Even on things like rupees, as you pick them up, every time you start the game save file,
it reminds you what a rupee is the first time you pick it up in each time you start
up the game. Dear God.
Crazy. So, things like this, I don't know.
I just don't... Something about, like, the nature of these games, it just doesn't jive well with me.
And so, stadium events.
Athletic World is a no.
And that's that.
That is really that.
I don't have anything else to say.
Anybody else have anything to say?
I think that covers it.
All right. Well, guys, you know where to find us at www.nostalgiacast.com.
We've been having a lot of people write in lately, so I'd love if people would just continue
to write in. You can do that at contactatnostalgiacast.com.
That's our email. There's also on the website, there's a form submission that a lot of people use, too.
Use those. So, yeah, use that as well.
And who knows?
Maybe you'll be talked about on the podcast.
Maybe you'll get a nice email from me.
Sometimes I pretend to be Joe and Sean.
And write back to you guys, too, if you address them instead of me.
Do you actually do that?
No. Okay.
No one's ever talked to you guys.
No one ever addresses you guys.
I'm actually offended now.
They did ask. One time, though, we were asked, what was Joe thinking when he voted slalom essential?
We'll get to that. Yeah.
I got my piece to say.
Okay. No, no, I understand.
So, you know, it's fun stuff like that.
We love seeing the community engagement.
We love all of you guys for listening.
And feel free to check out the Twitter page, which is at NostalgiaCast, where we post, like,
all sorts of gaming media stuff that relates back to the NES.
And I don't think it's just, like, things you can Google.
I think I try to make it really interesting.
So, check that out.
Just kind of scroll down the feed.
Lots of interesting stuff. Speaking of interesting, Sean?
Yes. What do you have to say?
Go to the bathroom.
What? Go to the bathroom.
If you haven't gone to the bathroom yet today, go to the bathroom.
Go to the bathroom. This podcast is over, so now you can.
Or if you were listening to this podcast on the toilet, that's fine, too.
You could have done it the whole time.
If you were holding it in just while you were listening to this, that's weird.
Also, I find that it's fun to listen to this podcast while you play, like, a game, such as, like, American Truck Simulator or Euro Truck Simulator.
Okay. Not everybody is into that, but thank you for calling that out.
I would also say that it's fun to listen to podcasts when you're driving to work or you're on the commute, like, in a subway car.
I heard you're going to do a bonus episode where you just mention all the ways to listen to Nostalgia.
I would also suggest, if you have it, you could listen to podcasts on the various home improvement devices from the big tech companies.
Yeah, like Jolly Rancher.
Yeah. Jolly Rancher is coming out with their own home device.
Yeah. Are they?
Yep. Okay.
No, no, no. Jolly Rancher.
You could also...
It's called Jolly Home. You could also watch an episode of Home Improvement, but turn the volume all the way down and take an aux cable, plug it into your TV, and put that podcast over Home Improvement.
In fact, Sean's been working on his Tim Allen grunts for that specific reason.
We've been meaning, you know how, like, people do Pink Floyd and The Wizard of Oz, and they, like, sync those up?
We've been meaning to, like, accidentally sync up to Home Improvement.
But it just hasn't happened yet.
Actually...
If it has happened, you should email us and let us know which episodes sync up.
I'm really sorry about all this.
I'm Michael Esposito.
You can find me on atespositofilm on Twitter, and I'll talk to you soon.
Thanks for listening.